et bien voilà regarder qui gît à côté de
moi
regardez bonjour eliane gauthier julie
jours quand allez-vous très bien très
bien
bonjour patrick bricka oui françois
comme moi vous êtes tellement françois
c'est ce qui m'amuse c'est que ce matin
vous avez une chemise qui ressemble un
peu à celle que portait françois autre
esprit la fête c'est un hommage était
rendu
bonjour messieurs du snav alors très
bien c'était bien de rajouter monsieur
parce que christophe dit toujours du
snop ce qui est vraiment très humiliant
pour moi on peut voir l'enregistrement
de talent heure-là il a dit plusieurs
fois et je veux parler de monsieur on
fait un petit coucou à mademoiselle futé
au facteur je crois qu'au recteur il est
dans le midi il n'a pas pu voir avec
nous il en a de la chance
alors qu'est ce que c'était si internet
qu'on vient de voir
alors ça c'est est ce qu'on appelait
nous les séquences intercalaires qui
était destinée à couper un peu
l'émission le plateau pour que relancer
l'attention et aussi à être parfois un
clin d'oeil pour les les plus grands de
façon à ce que l'émission soit pas un
ghetto pour les tout petits
alors des séquences comme la vache noire
haute comme anti vol étaient des
séquences à china road a eu beaucoup de
succès parce que quand on a préparé
l'émission il ya beaucoup de jeunes dans
l'équipe de matin bonheur
j'ai entendu pendant une semaine la
vache noire à l'ol et je crois que nous
avons le téléphone le téléphone n'arrête
pas de sonner à matin bonheur nous avons
un appel je crois que sandrine est en
ligne
oui bonjour sandrine bonjour est ce que
je peux je peux vous demander votre âge
sandrine a generation casimir vous lie
nos enfants est avec nous alors vous
pouvez poser votre question et j'espère
un vide
moi j'adore le regarder je regardais
quand j'étais tout petit et je me
souviens qu'un jour je rentrais de
l'école mes parents va aller la télé
couleur et j'ai regardé pour la première
fois qu'elle diminuera en couleur j'ai
trouvé un magic les couleurs
vers le rouge le jaune orange et je suis
vraiment oui vous êtes ému et justement
à ce propos christophe me disais tout à
l'heure que on voyait casimir vers tous
les gens qui l'avaient en noir et blanc
général le voyez vert et ont été surpris
à près de le découvrir orange est ce que
c'était votre cas pour moi la couleur
quand les couleurs ça a été vraiment mal
et ça a été le choc et les devis sont là
nous a même l'émotion que moi j'ai vécu
quand les puits quand j'étais enfant
merci beaucoup sandrine de votre
témoignage je crois que ça nous touche
beaucoup ça touche beaucoup tous nos
amis sur le plateau est ce qu'on va
revoir merci sandrine de nous avoir
appelé ça au revoir est ce que est ce
que on va peut-être voir casimir un jour
c'est possible on n'en sait rien du tout
de toute façon c'est pas nous qui
pouvons dire je crois que quand on est
où comédiens ou acteurs on a toujours
envie d'être vue de repasser mais c'est
aux responsables de la chaîne ou des
chaînes qu'il faut poser cette question
là très bien s'il ya encore des gens qui
ne vous connaissent pas je dis bien s'il
y en a encore est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter rapidement vous présenter
en tant que personnage de livres aux
enfants julie c'était qui julie bat
julie c'était
john gotti déjà d'abord et toujours
eliane gauthier et puis c'était
effectivement quelque chose que un
personnage que j'ai complètement essayé
de coller à moi mais la caractéristique
à la baisse et quelle était la grande
soeur de casimir mais elle faisait des
bêtises comme lui et ça les enfants
adoraient françois c'était complice et
elle se mettait en colère souvent les
enfants me disait on adore quand tu te
mets en colère
et ça et quand tu fais des bêtises donc
ça c'était une notion importante c'était
des bêtises oui c'était toujours très
raisonnable oui très raisonnable et
beaucoup de tendresse un personnage très
tendre avec et qu'est ce qu'ils avaient
dans votre kiosque l art y avait le
tunnel de léonard et vous chers les
emails de là il y en a
oui oui dans lequel je tombais temps en
temps art il avait oublié de fermer la
trappe
il y avait d'autres puis on va y avait
toutes mes petites affaires parce que
j'ai toujours des gros stack avec plein
de choses de danse des bonbons dans des
grands beaucoup dehors il ne fait pas de
temps ce qu'il faut dire
pour julie donc la marchande de bonbons
c'est que je voyais pas du tout un
personnage comme il y adjoignant un
personnage beaucoup plus sérieux et puis
le jour où eliane est venu me voir dans
mon bureau pour auditionner donc je
l'avais jamais vu encore et je lui ai
demandé comment on fait un curriculum
vitae des photos etc
et à ce moment là je l' ai vu plonger
dans un énorme sac où elle a disparu y
avait des débris qui volaient dans tous
les sens et j'ai trouvé le personnage
tellement drôle que j'ai décidé d'en de
coller ça et de et que ça serait
désormais le personnage de julie et bien
avant de parler avec françois et
monsieur du snob
nous allons revoir un petit medley de
casimir regarder au revoir yves cette
fois
voilà mes très chers amis ma très chère
amie
soyez la bienvenue soyez la bienvenue
bonjour casimir
j'ai prévenu françois est le facteur
il devrait arriver à c'est parfait
léonard merci et nous sommes un jour du
synode est mort du sida en chine vous
plaît s'il vous plaît j'aime il j'ai
l'honneur avantage de vous présenter
toujours plus loin toujours plus fort
dans mes sculptures ou voici pour
dernier chef-d'oeuvre
je mentais bon ça va pas du tout et le
bocal là mais oui mais moi je peux
retrouver avec le petit lapin rose jeu
ça m'a pas du tout du tout bonjour
monsieur duhamel je l'aimé tant kazemi
gens de manger une comtesse plus tard il
comptait encore ses comptes est
imaginaire non mais c'est toujours la
même chose
c'est toujours quand on a besoin de lui
il a un rendez vous important
et moi je ne supporte plus ses comptes
est imaginaire une petite foule et les
enfants là ça y est on est arrivé bravo
à vous étiez en super forme aujourd'hui
et bien maintenant vous allez prendre
une bonne douche et on se retrouve tout
à l'heure
d'accord sarah kazemy oui très mal merci
à laurent que tu arrives tu es donc je
ne supporte plus les contextes de
monsieur du soir avoue enfin casimir
tu sais très bien que c'est conteste
n'existe pas mais justement c'est ça qui
m'agace parce que tu voudrais sans doute
qu'elles existent mais non je ne veux
plus jamais entendre parler des quotas
est le monsieur du snob
bonjour casimir
tu sais on est toujours de bonne humeur
quand on va faire une bonne action ça
c'est très vrai et s est vu l'action eh
bien j'ai décidé de vous faire un cadeau
à tous les trois parce que vous êtes
tellement gentil avec moi mais c'est
qu'on t'aime beaucoup casimir le faisons
là rien d'extraordinaire mais si si si
j'y tiens beaucoup
et puis ça me fait tellement plaisir
mais dis moi quel souvenir pourquoi
aujourd'hui sans aucune raison a si
justement il y a une très bonne raison
laquelle eh bien j'ai tout rangé chez
moi et j'ai retrouvé des objets dont je
ne savais pas quoi faire alors au lieu
de les jeter à la poubelle
j'ai pensé vous les donnez vous avez
demandé quelque chose
un éclair au chocolat mais voilà aux
farceurs tu me fais peur pour moi petite
balle
j'aimerais que tu me prépares un bon
gloubiboulga séance j'avais complètement
oublié et là horreur du gloubiboulga ne
soit pas trop triste casimir nous allons
partager avec les vrais pas vous vous
êtes le véritable ami or dans un grand
saladier
oui tout de suite nous allons partager
mais bien sûr tient vite passe à la fois
rue à la tiens voilà voilà
le sandwich au jambon
bonjour leclerc met les pieds on peut
faire un gloubi boulga avec nab et qu'on
les mêmes menus mais nous sommes et nous
allons partager
casimir
[Musique]
voilà matin bonheur reçoit ce matin
l'île aux enfants
il ya des discussions sur le plateau
c'est vrai que 1
que de souvenirs oui alors françois qui
étiez vous eh bien je crois que dans
l'esprit de christophe l'auteur le papa
de tous les personnages moi je
représente m qui peut le le grand frère
des enfants peut-être aussi un petit peu
le papa sans que ce soit sans que ce
soit dit vraiment et dans cet univers
dans lequel il y avait pas mal de de
délire j'étais un petit peu l'élément
raisonnable les mots modérateur et quand
vraiment là la coupe déborde et un petit
peu j'étais là pour me
par contre ce que j'aimais beaucoup
aussi c'est non à côté de ce personnage
je pouvais mais aussi d'élire et à
travers eux beaucoup de personnages de
composition qui avait expérimenté cette
offre très bien parti je me sentais un
peu comme un grand frère
ben voilà c'est ce que c'est ce que je
vous disais donc il a réussi il a réussi
sa cour et en voilà si son coût alors
monsieur du snob
oui jean louis terreau angles oui qui
étiez vous le personnage principal de
l'île aux enfants
mais non
casimir est une marionnette mais qu'une
marionnette oui à on l'a vu un objet
d'ailleurs on le voit d'ailleurs nous
dit il n'était pas un original et je me
suis non et je ne suis pas un numéro non
plus et j'étais le personnage principal
c'est sa valeur peut être à petit j'ai
grignoter j'étais à un personnage
secondaire puis petit à petit
bon voila j'ai réussi à devenir le
personnage principal plus intéressant à
mon avis intéressant parce que
franchement il était trop non c'est vrai
il faisait rire autant les tout petits
que les plus grands alors que les autres
des bonds lui n'était pour les petits et
bien pour les petits léonard pour les
trayons moi j'étais pour tout le monde
même les mamies me voyais d'ailleurs
j'ai les mamies dans la rue qui me
disent vous me rappelait mon enfance
très bien houston n'a pas changé il nous
le prouve
il ya une question qui revient
énormément aux standards et je sais que
dans l'équipe de matin bonheur on m'a
dit surtout tu la pause celle là c'est
qu'ils étaient julie pour françois alors
sa question vient alors oui je n'ai pas
prédire dit au départ non parce que de
toute façon
l'émission avait été écrite comme je les
dis pour aider les enfants qui
arrivaient à l'école donc à se sentir
mieux dans cet univers un peu compliqué
donc il y avait aucune structure
familiale y avait pas de parents il ya
personne n'était ni mariée ni la seule
structure familiale c'était casimir et
son cousin hippolyte
mais alors il y avait julien de fond
soir et alors là ce qui était
intéressant c'est qu'il ya des enfants
qui les mariés d'autres qui on faisait
le frère et la soeur
c'était une sorte si je peux me
permettre de perdre espagnols m'ont
amené la structure familiale qu'on a
qu'on anglais vont se poser des
questions et moi il m'est même arrivé
choses assez assez rigolote que des
enfants prennent ma femme qui est toute
blonde pour julie dans la rue ah oui
donc on les je crois que les enfants ont
pensé pendant longtemps même si elle est
à présent hors antenne un petit sketch
ou si julie attendait un enfant le jour
de l'accouchement dans le kiosque
il y avait là plus y avait léonard
casimiri politique du snob et le facteur
qui attendaient pour savoir à qui ils
appartiennent
[Rires]
ça ne regardez pas les enfants une autre
question est qui
écrivez les scénarii qui écrit parce que
une émission par jour vous tourniez dans
les conditions du direct je présume
ah non non non non non on reprenait on
travaille on avait un système de deux
répétitions deux jours de répétition
trois jours de tournage et dans lesquels
on tournait à peu près 25 minutes mais
en huit heures de tournage est vraiment
avec des reprises
alors pour bien faire ce stage on vient
faire ce genre d'émission et de travail
il faut écrire qui écrivait au début ça
a été moi qui écrit les premiers
épisodes
et puis très rapidement après quand même
une centaine d'épisodes j'ai eu peu à
peu le renfort des comédiens parce que
c'était eux qui était le mieux placé
pour écrire des histoires aussi patrick
vous avez qui a eu un joli ça c'est
exceptionnel parce que on a on pouvait
se faire plaisir à dire que pendant le
tournage on se disait tiens la prochaine
fois je ferai bien un hommage à tati
chaplin bien je ferai bien des on se
passerait bien des tartes à la crème
bon je tomberai bien habillé dans une
piscine est et on va faire un truc par
rapport aux enfants sur telle pédagogie
enfin chaque fois qu'on a une usine
réaliser vos rêves à leur examen mais ce
que je peux ajouter aussi s'est il pas
reconnaît que nous écrivions les uns les
autres nous nous écrivions par forcément
pour nous même des choses carrées
extraordinaire mais bon moi je me tiens
du snob je le verrais bien dans tes
l'événement monsieur et c'est envoyer
eux et liana
[Musique]